inventing a skateboard trick is
difficult enough but this man homemade
sports that are part of the tricks
themselves
the most difficult board I've worked on
was the tri-fold 360 Flip I did recently
yeah that one I had to make at least
five iterations of the board and it
would constantly break meet Matt
tomasello professional skateboarder and
amateur engineer Reinventing a sport
with a unique approach I think the board
modification just adds a layer of
complexity that kind of steps away from
competitive skateboarding and more into
like an art form
it's definitely to me the most
interesting skateboarding there are no
rules probably skateboard as long as I
can physically do it
now to fall on the ground
[Applause]
oh boy
Matt spends countless hours testing any
of his 50 plus boards all in a space as
DIY as his own work this is a
semi-abandoned parking lot me and my
friends built some ramps here to skate
on
this one did not take me long to make
but it took me forever to land the
tricks that I intended to do with it you
do half a flip and then it does one and
a half flips back when I land on it
upside down or it hits the ground upside
down it pops and it can oh God I knew
that was gonna happen too I wanted to
design a board where the truck goes
around the entire skateboard there's one
spring-loaded hinge that should just
Propel the truck around the board
this one took a while to figure out it
freely flips both ways done a few tricks
where both sides flip at the same time
and sometimes in opposite directions
this one's probably my favorite
I honestly would rather destroy my body
I'm awkward
[Music]
as far as like taking you beating the
board will usually break before I'm
physically harmed enough to stop I think
falling is like the most important trick
in skateboarding it's an inevitable
thing that's gonna happen if you learn
how to fall correctly you're going to be
able to just keep trying
always looking to test a new idea Matt
volunteered to engineer a new board from
scratch in his bedroom Workshop so I was
in my room this is where I do my
building yeah I got a little workbench
over here and giant stack of boards
usually donated from local skateboarders
and friends so I've been thinking about
this board where half of the board falls
down on cables and a lever brings it
back up before you land
[Music]
I have a Sketchbook with a bunch of my
old stuff but lately I've just been
building like rough drafts sketching it
is way harder I wish I had like a CAD
program I could just test the physics on
but maybe I'll get there one day
sometimes I get inspiration if I see a
machine or one of the boards like got
inspiration by seeing a gate in
somebody's backyard draw a line I think
it needs to be cut I decide where to cut
based on how long the lever is and how
much time I have for the board to come
back together because is usually working
with anywhere from like a half a second
to to maximum but if it's just flat
ground trick in the air you really only
have like a half a second course of a
second calculated
nothing needs to be perfect just needs
to work once I have a spare nose might
as well use it instead of cutting up a
new one reduce reuse
so they overlap because this would never
hold anyone it's all a balancing act
like weight distribution from the front
truck to the back truck nothing's gonna
work if there's anything in between that
can fold in I'm just going to drill the
holes where the cabling is going to go
probably spend like hundreds of hours
building different boards in here just
tinkering with things
[Music]
the wrist board I built I think it was
just a single hinge attached to the
truck I pop and the momentum causes it
to do a heel flip late I saw the physics
get altered from the moving part and I
was like oh this is interesting you can
use it to your advantage
I've been in Boston my whole life
there's not many spots to skateboard so
you got to work with what you got I
think that's just natural progression
how can I find a way to adapt to my
environment and make it interesting
this is the self not as board there's
this check on a skateboard called the
NADA spin invented by natas kappas he
ollied onto a fire hydrant and grabbed a
pole and spun around and this is like
way way back yo Andy what year did
notice do the NADA spin
okay this one when you ollie the back
truck is attached to a metal bracket you
can stall and you can spin around even
manual down a bank this one just took a
while to figure out the proper angle for
the Stop on the L brackets and spring
load tension as you want it to hit as
soon as you're at the peak of your Ollie
because otherwise it's going to kick
back and then just fold right back under
this board is kind of like a book I
guess the only trick I've ever done on
this is a kickflip where in the air it
will open and close the momentum of it
closing kind of finishes the last like
quarter of the flip it's pretty
impractical for anything else this one
actually did not take me long to make
it's just cut in half with a
spring-loaded hinge essentially just
wind it up and you do a trick it's just
release
you can flip the front or the back
depending on where your foot is you can
adjust the tension so it'll close faster
or slower depending on the trick the
other ones you saw where it was mostly
like flipping two coins the timing it's
impossible to stop it this one's
actually more on track
still working on this one is supposed to
do one and a half flips and then bounce
off these compression springs can't
quite figure out the timing of it still
uh work in progress my success rate is
probably
say about twenty percent maybe 25.
gonna build a lever luckily I have some
leftover parts for that we're going to
use some metal cabling to bring back the
second half of the board threading the
cabling through the holes giving its
track to reel back on
my foot will essentially be on the lever
while I'm doing the trick and then it's
going to slide off the Reel is going to
retract when the lever closes and that's
what's going to cause the board to come
back together
so now I'm just securing the cabling
this clamp I made out of some old metal
brackets it doesn't come flying off
now I'm going to set the tension of the
spring control how fast it's going to
close and I usually adjust it like at
the spot based on you know how long the
Trick's taking
Matt returned to the skate park hopeful
to make his new creation work so we're
at the skate spot just gonna
try this board out I'm gonna try to
slide down here have the board drop
while sliding and then reel back up
right away
oh my God
I can't get over it need weight in the
front I might just have to take a
different approach at it
foreign
[Applause]
didn't work but luckily 5-0 worked out I
think that's it no matter how many tries
his boards can take Matt loves the
freedom of the process
they're trying to make rules in the
Olympics and everything but you can do
absolutely whatever you want nobody can
throw a flag on the field and say you
know you didn't do it right
[Music]
[Applause]